[Musique]
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
quartiers sensibles la communication
semble bel et bien rompue vous croyais
aussi la loi ou jouer leurs attaques ces
dernières années les bavures policières
semble s'être multipliées il faut dire
que les autorités ne sont plus les
bienvenus dans certains quartiers comme
d'une nouvelle marche de solidarité en
soutien adama traoré avait lieu ce jeune
homme tué suite à un contrôle de police
en 2016
durant cette manifestation samir eliès
manque du mouvement immigration banlieue
a pris la parole en s'adressant
directement à la police des accusations
lourdes qui rappelle un discours anti
flics souvent trop démesuré
alors comprenez vous ce qu'ils appellent
la police à ne plus aller dans les
quartiers sensibles
merci à mme albert tutsi d'être avec
nous merci d'être là on se connaît un
peu vous êtes déjà venu voir un voilà
merci fondatrice du collectif urgence
police assassines et merci à thierry
ehrmann un caire policiers dédiés
guéparde départemental du rassemblement
national
merci d'être là également alors cette
question c'est vrai que maintenant ça a
été la grande question du jour j'ai vu
sur les réseaux sociaux ça n'a pas
arrêté comprenez vous ce qu'ils
appellent la police à ne plus entrer
dans les quartiers sensibles
ici autour de la table ont dit non sauf
gilles verdez alors on va donner la
parole à nicolas pernikoff qui dit non
et après on aura bien sûr j'aimerais
avoir l'avis d'amal et bien sûr de syrie
ahmad inquiet oui je trouve ça honteux
et inacceptable c'est pas possible qu'on
apprenne à vivre ensemble et qu'on
respecte et apprécie je dirais on ne
peut pas dire que les policiers il ya
même des sondages qui sortent en disant
que soit disant plus de 70% des
policiers seraient racistes
vous savez bien qu'il ya aucune impunité
policière c'est à dire que à un moment
donné effectivement des cons il peut y
en avoir partout mais bien évidemment
quand il ya des cons chez les flics ils
sont punis immédiatement et le
gouvernement s'en occupe maintenant ce
qu'il faut arriver à faire absolument
c'est qu'il puisse y avoir un dialogue
demain intelligente entre les banlieues
et la police pour que tout le monde
puisse vivre ensemble et sereinement et
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
depuis dix ans je dirais un espèce de
dérapages qui est absolument je trouve
terrible pour tout le monde alors le
fuck dit lewis et gilles verdez j'ai dit
oui parce que j'ai voulu aller au-delà
des mots les mots sont durs mais au delà
des mouilles à la détresse via le
malheur il ya l'abandon il yal isolement
de gens qui vivent dans les quartiers et
qui n'ont plus d'interlocuteur et quand
il voit les policiers ça se passe mal
donc je trouve qu'une certaine sagesse
de dire ne venez plus si c'est pour ça
donc effectivement il faut refonder le
dialogue mais pour le moment je
comprends ces gens qui sont en
souffrance abandonnés dans les quartiers
et qu'ils disent
aidez-nous j'ai pris ça pour un cri du
coeur dont je peux pas entendre ses deux
frangins en plus du tout en sécurité à
dire que chaque fois qu'on va voir un
policier s'annonce mal enfin deux ou
trois pourcent d'aider des policiers pum
stade et courent partout aujourd'hui jc
mais ne tient pas ce genre de nabucco
ici d'ailleurs j'ai peut-être peut-être
bien sûr c'est possible alors à mal à
mal est ce que pour vous faut interdire
l'entrée de la police dans les quartiers
où est ce que c'est une mesure trop
extrêmes alors je peux comprendre sa
mire eliès quand il s'exprime sur sur le
alors c'est ça mais l'idée est qu'il y
en a parlé
lors de ce rassemblement voilà et c'est
ça c'est vrai qu'a fait énormément
parler quand on vous dit ça ce que vous
trouvez c'est trop voilà c'est trop
extrêmes lorsque vous dites oui je
comprends oui je comprends puisque la
situation est telle aujourd'hui dans les
quartiers que quand les policiers
interviennent c'est de façon violente
on le voit bien qu'il n'ya pas le même
traitement quand il s'agit des quartiers
qu'ailleurs
donc nous ce qu'on a envie c'est que
quand elle intervient cette police
quelle qu'elles interviennent dans le
cadre légal et qu'elles ne dépassent pas
le cadre les gages aux tout simplement
voulais quand même mais qu'elles
interviennent moins qu'elle ne soit pas
violente c'est à dire on le voit bien
dans le dans le comportement de certains
policiers qui viennent dans les
quartiers on voit bien qu'ils sont là
pour venir casser des gens alors votre
ferme amine ben tout petit a été abattu
d'une balle dans le dos 2012 lors d'une
course poursuite à noisy-le-sec
oui donc vous vous n'êtes pas aussi
extrême vous dites ils viennent mais
vous voulez que voilà que ce qu'ils
soient voie la plus juste posé parce que
si je dois voilà si je dois résumer
votre votre pensée vous dit pas il voit
plus et doivent plus du tout venir dans
les banlieues dans l'état actuel et le
comportement qu'elle a cette police je
suis d'accord avec ça mais reyes mais
elle doit intervenir dans le cadre légal
et pas dépasser le cadre légal faire
subir de la violence à deux jeunes
hommes dans les quartiers juste hier
j'ai encore un papa qui m'a appelé qui
me dit à bagneux ça s'est passé à
bagneux son fils a eu peur
il a couru ils étaient 3,4 gamin il
s'est retrouvé à ressortir du
commissariat tuméfié il a 14 ans
pourquoi il ya eu peur de quoi voilà il
a eu peur il a couru parce que c'est un
policier qui qu'on surnomme qu'on
surnomme hitler qui est bien connu pour
passer à tabac deux jeunes garçons et il
en a subi les conséquences
donc ce jeune garçon il avait rien fait
son papa m'a appelé qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
donc voilà c'est ça la problématique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
comment se comporte comment ces
policiers se comportent et quelles
solutions
on doit trouver pour que ces policiers
soit soit mis de côté que qui qu'ils
soient
la culture c'est comprenez vous ce
qu'ils appellent la police à ne plus
rentrer dans les quartiers sensibles
liées aux jantes on vous dit non
moi je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée
parce que justement ces quartiers
réputés difficiles réputé sensible ce
sont des endroits où justement on a
besoin de sécurité
en revanche ses propos ce qui démontre
c'est que on a un vrai problème en
france avec l'image de la police la
police et une sale image et quand on lit
ça on a l'impression que la police c'est
un parti politique c'est un groupement
idéologique que les policiers sont
racistes c'est pas vrai les policiers
c'est des hommes et des femmes qui font
un métier très important déjà qui essaye
de bien faire leur métier
par contre je pense qu'il faut faire un
vrai travail sur l'image de la police ça
va pas qu'on dise qu effectivement j'ai
lu ça aussi que soi-disant 80% des
policiers sont racistes
je pense que c'est pas vrai je pense que
c'est n'importe quoi alors il ya des
gens qui réagissent à sur les réseaux
sociaux ayant qui dit dans les quartiers
il ya aussi des familles qui sont bien
contentes de voir que la wii donc
exactement mais je pense que la pire
chose qui pourrait arriver à ces
quartiers et aux centaines d'habitants
qui sont dans ces quartiers c'est que
précisément la police n'y est plus parce
que là il serait dans un sentiment
d'insécurité absolue tant qu il faille
renouer un dialogue ça je vous comprends
très bien là dessus mais en revanche
dire qu'il faut que ces gens là sont les
dangers dans les cités c'est sûr il
suffit d'ailleurs mode et marc dunkerque
vous vous en pensez quoi de ce qu'ils
disent que la police ne doit plus
rentrer dans les quartiers sensibles
je rappelle que oui vous êtes policier
oui tout à fait moi j'en pense que s'il
n'y a pas de contrôle social exercé par
une police républicaine il sera exercée
par des caïds de cités et je pense qu'il
vaut mieux être contrôlé par des
policiers qui si jamais ils dérivent
doivent rendre compte de leurs actes
devant une institution qu'est l'igpn
plutôt qu'être livré aux mains de caïds
qui se sont dans le trafic de drogue
non je reste passera les quartiers
sensibles en fait j'ai beaucoup
travaillé dans les quartiers sensibles
il faut savoir qu'à une économie
parallèle qui est complètement implantée
cette économie parallèle elle génère du
travail génère de l'argent il ya aussi
qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont très
très heureux de vivre dans ces quartiers
voilà est qui qui est avec qui ces
autres qui ça se passe très très bien
je vous le dis moi je vois plein de
choses au sziget qui aide qui aide
énormément des familles parce que tout
le monde s'en plaint on dit que c'est
des ghettos on dit que sont les gens qui
sont abandonnés
non mais on pour autant moi je pense que
comme pour les policiers vous faites ça
raille aussi une généralité ici je
parlais il ya un instant des policiers
on disait qu'ils étaient tous racistes
là je suis pas d'accord avec ça non plus
là sur ce que vous dites je suis pas
d'accord non plus moi je vous dire il ya
je vous dire il ya une fraternité
il ya une solidarité aussi dans les
quartiers qu'on voit souvent pas
ailleurs et je vois là je vous dis moi
j'étais j'ai travaillé dans les
quartiers j'avance et je suis sud est
dit là où c'était un quartier voilà
ouais ouais il faut dire qu'il y avait
une solidarité incroyable mon père est
médecin a été médecin encore odile à
lajunie y voyez ils étaient tous heureux
de vivre dans des quartiers dont les
cités c'est curieux parce que je suis
issu du quartier du mirail et j'ai pas
connu cette solidarité oui on entend le
mirail à toulouse on peut pas dire que
ça soit n'ont plus envie d'être des
traîtres d'aller d'aller rencontrer les
autres allaient rencontrer les gens dès
lors j'étais gamin mais bien évidemment
que j'en avais envie dès les années 90
quand mes parents ont commencé à vouloir
quitter le quartier où on avait des
difficultés parce qu'on était issu d'une
famille pauvre et qu'on ne pouvait pas
se loger comment comme on le souhaitait
on a dû partir parce que notre voiture
elle était cassé tous les jours moi
j'avais mes voisins de palier qui se
faisait racketter chaque fois qui
rentrait c'était la peur au ventre que
je devais rentrer quand j'entends dire à
pied le jour dont excusez moi c'est
quand même eu six à sept est réel car il
ne faut pas en faire une généralité
comme on a pu le comme on a pu le faire
sur les policiers il ya un instant je
vous dis moi je ne garde général bvg par
tueries ont créé le problème qu'on a
aussi et je le dis c'est aussi un
problème dont dans les médias ou autre
des clichés à 90 pour sow on monte que
les mauvais côtés des cités des
banlieues des quartiers et on dit
quartiers sensibles
pourquoi parce que ça fait du
sensationnalisme que ça marche en
audience ce repas se mentir voilà ils
vous diront dit la vérité donc à la
plaque ils font ça aujourd'hui j'ai
rarement vu une émission au montrer la
solidarité qui peut y avoir dans les
quartiers il ya trop cession des
associations les grands frères qui font
un travail incroyable dans les quartiers
je vous lis donc c'est vrai que moi je
vous dis là on parle d'un truc et c'est
ce qui m'énerve c'est que c'est céder
pour moi vous fait des généralités
autant chez les policiers que dans les
quartiers
vous faites de la politique c'est qu'en
fait vous vous créez un raccourci
la banlieue racaille caïd drogue le
trafic et demi si j'ai fait désormais
police avait à vendre avant de rejoindre
l engagement politique et je les connais
pas mais bon moi je fais sur la partie
l'alfa souvenait pas se trouve sa
famille de d'appeler de dire qu'il ya
que des rats ces gens là puisque
effectivement c'est pas le cas alors ça
c'est pas le cas si vous avez des doutes
sur un plateau pouvaient pour peaux des
langues et effectivement il ya 11 est
imminent yahia quel biais ya des
problèmes il est est un fait il ya des
gens qui ont besoin d'un peu de ce
qu'ils sont ils se sentent en danger
d'accord mais vous vous avez dit voilà
vous dites banlieue cité racaille trafic
et voilà à mal ce qu'elle a dit tout à
l'heure elle elle dit je ne veux pas que
la police ne doit pas je veux qu'ils
aient un nouveau dialogue qu'on reparte
en taille alors je vous dire qu'on
voulait dialoguer des délinquants
valoriser mortier si je m'en voulais
vous dialoguez avec des trafiquants jour
en jour expliqué comment voulaient
dialoguer sedera je n'ai jamais autant
les policiers que les jeunes de calories
au contraire ils n'ont qu'une envie vous
dis c'est que ce dialogue est une chose
et kate jaoui jeanne les quartiers peu
moi j'ai toujours très bien dialoguer
avec les gens des quartiers populaires
vous savez je dialogue avec eux quand
j'étais policier c'est un effort
j'arrive à avoir de très bons rapports
avec eux mais à côté de ça avec les
choufs et avec les vendeurs mais
forcément j'avais un dialogue et qu'il
était un homme sont moins évidents qui
se passe mais oui quand on le sait c'est
logique c'est qu'aux deux personnes
commencent à s'insulter quand ça
commence à monter
il faudrait qu est un pas d'un côté et
un pas d'autres aujourd'hui il faut avec
la police aussi soin et essaye de
dialoguer et que les jeunes aussi
essayer de dialoguer je pense qu'il faut
maintenant des gens et aidé d'aînés ddd
et les voilà des émissaires des deux
côtés qui puisse faire que ça se passe
mieux parce qu'aujourd'hui moi je suis
persuadé voulait pas mettre sur un pied
d'égalité les délinquants et d'un
policier pour respecter la loi possible
si j'ai reçu plein de jeunes de banlieue
ici qui me disait on a peur aussi
on a on a peur quand on est on est dans
les banlieues et j'ai reçu aussi des
policiers qu'il dise on a peur d'aller
dans les monnaies missions plus les mecs
ya un problème les jeunes ils ont peur
d'y être et les policiers ils ont perdu
alors qu'est-ce qu'on aucun moment on
fait quoi solution parce que c'est ça
parce que dialoguer et s'insultent ai
dit vous êtes les mauvais et nous on est
les bons ou vie
ça se sera terminée aujourd'hui la
solution c'est quoi c'est quoi nous en
tant qu'association en tant que famille
victime parce que notre collectif
regroupe des familles de victimes qui
ont perdu un proche à la suite
d'opérations policières ou les histoires
se terminent par des non-lieux
cd non lieu à répétition sur des non
lieux ceux qui doivent y être qu'en bas
même quand la violence elle est
illégitime
d'accord c'est on est toujours durement
sanctionné par l'igpn et je vous assure
qu'on est très contrôlée dans le cas de
notre travail faute moi je travail en
brigade spécialisée de terrain pendant
des années je n'ai jamais tabassent les
persos des solutions vous n'êtes jamais
content c'est une solution alors la
solution c'est quoi ce format proposé en
mars 2020 l'année dernière c'est quoi
c'était l'application uv prp urgence
violences policières
c'est une affiliation qui a été pensée
pour les gens des quartiers populaires
qui subissent la stigmatisation au
quotidien la répression au quotidien les
passages hathaway ses films chez sa
compagne à l'en croire c'est con d'éric
s'attendent à un dialogue
l'application uv pc sur ce qui permettra
à mal ça va faire qu'une chose alors les
chassera les six mois terminés les
propos cm discours dans l'autre sens
pour faire le constat qu'on fait depuis
de nombreuses années
c'est que à chaque fois que des
policiers sont mis en cause dans des
affaires de violences policières
les caméras de pete les caméras piétons
celles qui ont été expérimentées dans
toute la france on se pose la question
si mal a mal à la normale non mais alors
je vous dire ouais mais un piéton de
foule et oui c'est pas le débat c'est
que j'ai aujourd'hui on essaie de
trouver des solutions mais je suis je
les fais mais pour voir s'il ya des
bavures policières
c'est pas la solution et une solution à
vos données série
très bonne de solution c'est que les
gens respectent la loi sont simplement
qu'ils en apprennent le vivre ensemble
c'est à dire dans la majorité des cas
les images sont effacés et dans un
documentaire où il ya un procureur qui
dit où on a la version policière où on
se contente de la version policière et
quand on a des images c'est des éléments
de preuve qui vous mais moi je vous dire
là là on n'est pas dans la solution
n'est pas dans la solution
ben là la solution pour moi c'est que ça
roule c'est pas envie le monde
les bavures policières qu'on veut ça va
s'arranger je pense à filmer les bavures
policières
plus personne ne peut nier qu'il existe
des violences vous savez moi dans le
cadre de mon activité syndicale aux
syndicats j'accompagne donc mon show
syndicats spip et j'accompagne des
collègues qui sont auditionnés par
l'igpn
et je peux vous garantir que le cas de
quoi la patrouille de police y'a aucun
cadeau qui ne leur est fait il y en a
qui sont sanctionnés très lourdement
très récemment et sans rien trahir sur
des faits d'un policier qui a dérapé en
tirant quelqu'un par les cheveux menotté
il a été sanctionnée d'une exclusion
temporaire de fonction ce qui est une
lourde
il a été sanctionné le chef qui était
présent a été sanctionné encore plus
gravement puisqu'il a pris deux ans
d'exclusion temporaire de fonctions
n'ont connu ni chez peine qui ne fait
pas de cadeau donc ça fonctionne le
contrôle de l'ap de la police par la
police regarde quelque chose qui
fonctionne on ne nous fait pas de cadeau
nous sommes très contrôlé et je préfère
que ce soit une police républicaine qui
est contrôlée qui interviennent dans les
quartiers plutôt que d'aider des
personnes qui sont hors de tout contrôle
complet on va avoir regardé le son à lui
oui à 19% nombre à 81%
merci à malvern tutsi d'avoir été avec
nous urgence police assassiné est la
fondatrice de ce collectif et merci
syrie ahmad inquiet d'avoir avec nous
j'ai rallié voulais rajouter un petit
bout non j'ai l'impression quand même
que marine vous madame la ghettoïsation
c'est pas la faute de la police
il fallait refaire le perdu
la république c'est pas la faute de la
police oui et en fait j'ai en fait le
débat il est complètement confisqué
rester et on a l'impression que
finalement on est abandonnés depuis des
années ont dès lors la police
oui on est forcément pour le
rassemblement national et c'est ça
aujourd'hui le problème on trouve dans
le débat et c'est très compliqué
d'apporter de la nuance non mais je vais
vous dire moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
contre eux mais qui réclament la justice
qui ont perdu un frère une agent la
justice ça ne passe pas et tant que ces
policiers ne seront pas condamnés à la
hauteur des faits il y aura toujours
qu'un policier a agi en tant que
policier en légitime et normal il est
normal qu'il ait un non lieu quand il ya
une légitime défense c'est normal c'est
rld